winter is here except the meanwhile in
the real world it's Easter and my kid
wanted to put a temporary tattoo on my
face so there we go so Game of Thrones
the rightful queen episode 2 of the
final season I hope everybody had a good
Easter and if it's not a holiday that
you celebrate I hope you had a nice day
that happened to be Easter for those
that it matters to so yeah I called the
previous episode of Game of Thrones a
little dull this was much less so and
took me a little bit to figure out why
because not that much more happens in
this than in the previous episode I
think a big part of the difference is I
really felt the sort of the threat of
the White Walkers showing up felt much
more immediate it felt like this is
something that's gonna happen at any
moment where as kind of what went on the
previous episode and the planning
regarding that it didn't feel
substantively different than what had
gone on at the end of the previous
series or just the way that the guys of
the wall have been talking about it
pretty much since the beginning you know
for if it ever comes and you know
talking about it in those terms so this
felt this felt more like the sword of
Damocles was properly hanging over the
proceedings and that worked well so I
like that there's some great
interactions and this that I that I
really really did enjoy quite a bit
between a number of different characters
I like all the stuff that goes on at the
fireplace between Oh God I came to
remember everybody who was there but
there's Brienne there's Jamie there is
Davos there's Tyrion there there's
torment
he's ridiculous I got I love him
and I really like bringing getting
knighted that was a really nice moment
another really nice moment that I like
quite a bit was Theon and Sansa
embracing and I will not lie I felt a
little lump in the throat on that one
that was uh as well done those well
delivered and it it was interesting with
the way it opened with Jamie cuz I I
almost immediately got vibes of
Littlefinger and how he ended but I'm
like he's not gonna die here so seeing
that move forward cool all that's good
like I said I'm feeling the tension
brand had a great just burn her Jamie
throwing that the things we do for love
line at him
I'm loving the symmetry that's going on
with with a brand right now I mean brand
spend a good chunk of the middle of this
show being very boring and as a
personality he's still kind of boring
but they're finding ways to like get
little bits in with him that that I I'm
getting a kick out of certainly and
seeing the different way people are
reacting to what they expect to be their
imminent death whether it be Sam or John
or tormund or that one little girl who
was who wanted to go and fight and and
Davos and Gilly basically kind of not
tricked her but like presented her with
a way of going in the crypt where it's
gonna be safest but still feeling like
but she gets to still feel like she's
not running away and hiding and that's I
mean that was great because that is in
so many ways a very true parenting
moment like there are times that in
order to get your kid to do something
it's not that you need to lie to them or
you need to trick them but it's not cool
white reverse psychology but you need
sometimes you need to reframe it into a
very specific way so that so that the
role of it and they'll go for it
I enjoyed all that that was good stuff I
I completely failed to mention Danny and
John in the previous episode I don't
like that like at all
for numerous rate I don't mean I don't
like it inherently I also actually think
it's being really poorly done to be
completely honest like here's here's the
big thing and the big issue for me and
this and like this is the reason why I
dislike probably nine out of ten
romantic subplots whether it be in TV or
movies or whatever the main reason I
dislike it is that they feel under
developed and we've seen these
characters together but not interacting
either enough or in a way that makes me
by when either one of them starts
spouting the word love in relation to
the other like interest sure crush yeah
fine love hold on and that's exactly
what I'm going through here they've had
some time together I get that there's an
attraction there but like love really
and I just I don't I don't buy it
I don't again i buyed the attraction but
it has not been developed enough for me
to buy that like previous episode was
Sansa who said the word love this time
Danny actually said it herself and I
hear that where I just Gras when I'm
like ah no no and now they're trying to
get additional tension out of this whole
idea where like he'll have a right to
the throne more than she will and I
don't know if that's supposed to like
create tension and be like who or
they're gonna be at odds now and I'm
like just struggling here going I know
you're trying to do a whole lovers torn
by their ambitions thing but I didn't
buy them his lover so I don't really
care about this like at all
and the other main issue I had with the
episode is somewhat related I I can't
decide okay here's the thing I don't
like it I can't decide how much I
dislike Arya pulling the I don't want to
die a virgin thing and that actually
really irritated me because I liked her
flirty moments with Gendry I did
legitimately enjoy those but something
about taking it to that that extra just
throwing that extra step and have her
have her basically say not in the exact
words but basically say I don't want to
die a virgin please take me like I what
what I will give the the episode credit
for is she is very much in command of
that choice so there's there's no weird
connotations there's no sense that you
know Gendry was pushing for it like this
if it was gonna happen
she as a character has been empowered in
in this situation in this position this
is very much what she wants in her
choice so cool so there's no weird vibes
there I still don't like it I still
think it's cheesy and look I know she's
a woman I know she's I know both the
actors in the character are grown adults
now but I still think of her in Sansa as
the stark girls and maybe that's on me
but it that adds to my whole oh do we
have to kind of feel to the thing so I
didn't care for that all that much
either but overall I did like this
episode I liked it a little bit better
than the previous one I felt like ladies
and well I don't think that much more
happen in terms of actual like if you
were to plot out the important plot
moments it was more care and quiet
character stuff maybe that's the
difference because like the previous
episode didn't feel like it had that
many character moments it was just
getting everybody in light to the
physical geographic location there
gonna have to be whereas here like it
felt like they were just taking some
beats in some moments and a breath to
remind us why we care about these
characters and in some cases it worked
some cases it didn't but I think that
that was a good way to go I kinda wish
they could have found a way to integrate
more of these kinds of character moments
into the previous episodes so that
didn't feel like quite such a profound
Tori moving the pieces on the board kind
of a thing but it's it's headed in a
good direction the tension is high I
will be curious to see how things go
down after this I think I'm I'm
reminding myself that this show does big
scale action very well hardhome was
great battle of the bastards was very
good you know they these can be really
terrific and I'm I am trying at the same
time as I am you know trying to be like
oh I'm pretty sure it's gonna be good
I'm also trying to not get overexcited
cuz I don't want to I don't want to feel
let down depending on what we get I'm a
little bit nervous that like if it
launches into the battle right away that
it's like nighttime okay I want to be
able to see what's going on but we'll
see we'll see you next week
so Game of Thrones second episode season
8 you seen it what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about a whole bunch of stuff to do
because there's buttons and links and
what else is there I don't know this
stuff it's all down there check it out
click on it but you also don't have to
if you really don't want to because at
the end of the day you're the council
I'm running the meetings so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]